[Musique]
après Saint-Pierre le 3 mai dernier
s'est au complexe sportif du bocage de
Sainte-Suzanne que les collégiens
participant au challenge Jo P 2024 à
Paris ce sont retrouvés ce mercredi 31
mai pour la suite des épreuves sportives
cette deuxième journée de compétition
s'est déroulée en présence du conseiller
départemental Jean-François nathivel et
des partenaires avec cet événement
international les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 à Paris et bien
nous avons eu dès le début l'ambition de
faire rayonner cet événement à travers
notre île pour d'une part développer
l'engouement autour de la pratique
sportive donc accompagné le monde
sportif en général et vu que nous avons
la compétence sur les collèges l'idée à
germer chez les services de pouvoir
proposer un événement qui allait
permettre de départager les collégiens
motivés pour constituer ensuite une
délégation pour être présent assez Jeux
Olympiques en 2024 et c'est une grande
fierté pour moi aujourd'hui d'être
présent surtout que je suis enseignant
d'EPS et que je sais à quel point les
valeurs véhiculées par le sport sont
importantes dans nos sociétés modernes
les 23 équipes sélectionnées se sont
retrouvés pour s'affronter autour de
plusieurs disciplines la course
d'orientation le breakdance le rafting
et le canoë-kayak
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ben moi je me
suis retourné en plus dans une vague et
du coup j'ai fait perdre un peu de temps
à galérer mais sinon ça va c'était cool
quand même content quand même de votre
performance
prochaine et dernière étape après cette
deuxième journée d'épreuve sportive le
concours d'éloquence des collèges qui se
tiendra le 23 juin prochain
[Musique]